[Applause]
calling out numbers for questions every
okay
yeah come on first question from 218 and
a 348 on Deck
I don't know if anybody heard
you hello my name is Thomas puscale from
the Slovak Republic a massive
congratulations I'm a huge visual
effects fan and what you did it's so
amazing but my uh question is this one
um is there a process that you use that
was unique to the film something that
hasn't been used before technology wise
I would have been proposed actually the
facial system is the newest thing and
JoJo talk you through it yeah we we
basically to try to get the characters
right you know to really capture what
the actors were doing we wrote neural
networks because just doing it the
old-fashioned way just wasn't it really
wasn't enough so just trying to to make
sure that it's you know you saw
Sigourney
see we're really lucky we get to watch
the actors and and it's just like a
small room it's like a stage play but
then we want to make sure that what
we're seeing goes out to everyone in the
movie so yeah that was probably a big
part of it you touched on it Sigourney
Weaver played a 14 year old girl and and
when when somebody when James had action
she embodied what is that character if I
would propose if she were wearing
prosthetic makeup she would be standing
in front of yesterday
348 and a film hounds on Deck
congratulations gentlemen I'd like to go
back to the visual effects under the
water with the actors you know
performing because the actors are really
performing we did a story in French
Polynesia with a stuntman who was
helping these actors and he said he was
erased in post-production in order of
course
was it hard to do that uh I don't think
you have that quite correct there's no
stop man erased in in post-production we
do use a stunt performers in order to
perform certain certain parts like the
elu and the the the obviously the ILO
has to it has to replace the sun
performer who drove the rig but the
actors themselves actually moved through
water in the in that way being drawn by
a a stunt guy who was driving what would
College elevator and and that was to
inform their performances so they really
felt you know you know the the effects
of the Dragon the water and all of it
and then that leads to The credibility
of the performance because that we
actually captured every minute detail of
their of those performances and brought
them for life on screen but we are
capturing performances there's no
photography at that point yeah we use
cameras for reference to understand what
everyone did but there's nothing to
erase because there's no photography
yeah
great we are now going to our virtual
Press Room film hounds go ahead
and going to hi Jed Wagman from
filmhounds in the UK
um I just want to ask you when you're
making a film that's taking so long to
make did you ever worry that technology
was gonna um evolve so rapidly that by
the time you the film came out the
technology you were using had sort of
become old and redundant by that point
no no Jeff it's it's the other way
around when we're making a film like
this we're writing the technology to
make it happen so um it's it's the Ink's
not dry by the time the movie's done so
yeah that's that's that's really not
something we're worried about it's more
the other way it's like is this stuff
going to work in time yeah if technology
evolves it's because of these guys
great we're going to 398 next and then
we're going back to our virtual Press
Room sa people
uh hi guys Jeff Snyder with the below
the line
um you introduced a groundbreaking
facial capture system in this film so
what's the next big technological
advancement that you're planning for
Avatar 3 and do you feel any pressure to
keep topping yourselves with these
sequels the first thing we're going to
do is is uh read the script again
because I have it right in a couple of
years and because everything we do is
driven by by story like we're at the
point right now and this happened after
the first film where Jim basically said
go and make a world I might point the
camera anywhere it might do anything
inside of it so we have to be prepared
for that but you have to do what the
what the script calls for visual effects
without a great story without great
acting is just not worth doing really
and to be honest technology for
technology sake is no good it has to
empower the art so we're not in a
position where we need to up ourselves
at a technical level it is truly about
emoting properly and connecting with our
audience if we do that then we keep we
keep making movies
and our last question will be our
virtual Press Room from sa people
hi I'm Cassie Joy from essay people
South Africa and congratulations on your
win uh could you please talk to us about
the sustainability assets of this film
um and the relationship with the visual
team
sorry say that again yeah
yeah
um yes the environmental messages and
efforts of the film
um and it's that relationship with the
visual team well look to be honest if
there was one there is a course we shoot
on a stage where we've we've uh
essentially a net zero you for print uh
from from a carbon standpoint our stages
are uh both stages are 28 000 square
feet they're completely covered in solar
and we generate enough uh enough energy
not just to say in our own production
but the whole lot so um it's it's
incumbent on us to walk the walk uh the
the message of the movie obviously is
about a symbiotic relationship with the
Earth and and sustainability that's one
we live every day you know down to we
actually had uh vegan catering on on set
for or I think about nine ten months
straight and that was for for uh the
reason of not wanting to convert anybody
which is but the idea that it's much
more sustainable uh as far as Farm to
right
thank you congratulations please have a
great night
[Applause]